good evening thanks for coming out
tonight
my name is Malika I'm a bookseller here
at the store and on behalf of the owners
and the staff I'd like to welcome you to
politics and prose it's a pleasure to
have Michael uborrow with us tonight
who's written an extensive biography of
Senator Pat McCarran Democrat from
Nevada who presided in Congress for
twenty years until his death in 1954
it's not only to study why Washington
had gone crazy Senator Pat McCarran and
the great American communists hunt is
not only this is not only a study of a
man sometimes overshadowed by fellow
Irish immigrant Joe McCarthy but also a
history of an era
Michael uborrow will speak for 20 or 30
minutes followed by a
question-and-answer session during which
we ask you to please use the audience
mic located right there and then we're
happy to sign books afterwards so please
join me in welcoming mr. Ybarra well
thank you very much I should say first
of all that my book Washington gone
crazy is not a study of current events
though I think as I go along that some
of you might see a few unfortunate
parallels between the 1950s and his
current period and American history well
Washington gun-crazy is foremost a
biography of Senator Patton Karen who
was a Democrat from Nevada most people
don't remember him very well these days
if you fly into Las Vegas you've
probably been through McCarran
International Airport but most people
going to Las Vegas for whatever reason
seem to have their minds on something
other than political history well
McCarran is important because primarily
I think of the times in which he lived
through and the way he made his mark
upon those times and the period I'm
talking about is generally remembered as
the McCarthy period named for the
phenomenom of McCarthyism which is named
after Senator Joe McCarthy whom most
people remember
for no other reason than for the
phenomenon but what I attempt to do in
this book is to disentangle McCarthy
from McCarthyism and placed in the
context of longer events and my time
horizon actually stretches back to the
New Deal where I see sort of the
formative political divisiveness that
eventually boils over into what we
member is McCarthyism well I'll start by
actually telling you a little bit of the
background of patna Karen and work up to
the McCarthy period Pat McCarran was
born in Reno in 1876 he was the son of
illiterate Irish immigrants and he spent
most of his youth very well isolated on
a farm down the Truckee River from Reno
really only people he came in contact
with him any consistent basis where his
mother and father's an only child and
occasionally they had seasonal seasonal
help on the farm but we can't really
grew up very much without learning to
play with others and in fact he never
would learn to play well with others
he started schools five years later than
he should have his father kept him back
on on the ranch because well he was
cheap labor so when you did start school
in the nearby town of Sparks he was
consequently five years older than all
of his peers and as I indicated he was
not naturally given to compromise in
fact really his life can best be
understood as operating in two modes one
was opposition and the other was
domination and again and again you see
this four first two-thirds laugh however
it was mostly in opposition
now McCarran went to the University of
Nevada at Reno I was a good student but
had to drop out of school around his
junior year because his father had an
accident on the farm could no longer
work Karen was forced to leave school
and take over the family business which
was mostly sheep herding so McCarran
became
and he spent a couple years grazing she
pined to the Sierras but he really had a
burning desire to make himself something
more than that so at the end of each day
when he was done in the Sheep trail he
would put the flock to bed build a
campfire crack his saddlebags and take
outlaw books and he taught himself law
around the campfire past the bar became
an attorney a defense attorney in Reno
mostly and he was actually a great
defense attorney very passionate very
dedicated to his clientele he would
represent accused abortion as became a
divorce lawyer know Reno obviously was
the capital of quickie divorces in
America I quickie divorce in those days
required six weeks of residency so he
actually shot into national controversy
at one point when he represented Mary
Pickford she wanted to divorce her
husband who Shaq actually hadn't seen in
years but they were still married on
paper so McCarran took care the divorce
and it became something of national
scandal when she got divorced one day
and a couple days later married Douglas
Fairbanks Jr well kind of a successful
lawyer and a good one but it's not
really what he wanted to do he really
wanted to get to Washington to write
laws instead of arguing about other
people's so for years he ran for the
Senate and he was never very success
whenever he got very far largely because
the Democratic Party in Nevada was
controlled by a political machine that
McCarran couldn't get along very well
with no surprise if you know anything
about his temperament which was it was
quite cantankerous and would often put
principle above magnetism one of his
Senate primary campaigns is an entire
platform consisted of opposition to the
World Court which was an issue that no
one in Nevada cared anything about at
all
so his guidance he went nowhere but
finally in 1932 the Democratic machine
nominated him or allowed him to be
nominated for the Senate that year
largely because they thought he would
lose and it's hard to remember at the
time that you know the Great Depression
was in its fourth year and you know one
of the low points of American history
and you know many people look like
capitalism was not succeeding that
democratic liberal capitalism was
actually something with failure compared
to perhaps alternative forms of
governance some people pointed to
Hitler's Germany or Stalin's Russia as
maybe more efficient ways to manage
modern economies and so you know it was
a quite a surprise when McCarran was
actually elected and so he goes to
Washington in 1933 on the coattails of
Franklin Roosevelt well the two of them
show up in Washington the same week and
by the end of the week they're on
opposite sides of one of the second
piece of the New Deal program actually
and so you know once again McCarran
didn't play well with others now he
supported enough of New Deal that he
could keep getting elected in Nevada and
he was ultimately elected to the Senate
four times you know McCarran was against
what he viewed as the New Deal
socialistic leanings except when that
involved bringing money to Nevada which
he was very eager to seek and quite
successful at that at one point the New
Deal gave more money per capita to
Nevada than any other state in the Union
and so McCarran continued to oppose much
of the New Deal however on ideological
grounds he was an conservative wing of
the Democrats and Roosevelt was really
reinventing or you know American
democracy is creating modern welfare
state involved in federal government and
things that it had never considered its
business before things like you know
preventing children from working you
know giving people over you know
compelling companies to pay people for
the amount of time they actually worked
providing disability and old-age
pensions you know basically everything
that we assumed
to be the government's job these days
was created by Roosevelt during the 30s
well you know McCarran spent most of the
30s in opposition to to the New Deal and
by this time we're about halfway through
the book but the core of the book is
really the second half
it starts in about the end of World War
two
now tremendous just come into the White
House after the death of Roosevelt and
McCarran has just come into the
chairmanship of the Senate Judiciary
Committee and now Truman and Roosevelt
should have gotten along fairly well
they were both people from small towns
roughly the same age had so much smaller
temperaments actually they were both
somewhat anti-establishment resentful of
the eastern liberals even though Truman
was very much of a liberal at heart he
actually disdained what he called the
professional liberals and by that he
really meant sort of you know East Coast
Ivy League types they know the kinds
that tended to dominate government in
those days you know McCarran shared
these antipathies but in practice the
two of them actually probably hated each
other as much as any politicians have
hated each other in Washington and that
hatred really drove a lot of what
happens over the next decade or so and
mccarran's position was very strategic
in on paper because he as chairman of
the Judiciary Committee was really in a
position where he could exercise an
enormous amount of power now under the
seniority system before it was reformed
in more recent decades a chairman of a
committee had basically untrammeled
Authority for matters before his
committee so if in mccarran's case
that's the district committee 40% of all
legislation in the Senate had to pass
through that committee so McCarran
couldn't outright kill any bill that he
did
but any bill that came into his
committee that he felt strongly about
had very little chance of actually
getting out of his committee and getting
to the floor unless he was satisfied by
some sort of horse trade or more often
or some sort of capitulation by one of
his Senate colleagues on some other
matter that mattered even more to him
McConnell was also in the position to
control patronage through this committee
now any senator who wanted to nominate a
crony or an ally to the federal bench
the name of a judge makes him a federal
marshal or a US Attorney in their state
had to get that nomination through
mccarran's committee if the president
wanted to name an attorney general that
nomination had to go to McClaren's
committee so you know on paper that was
a lot of power and practice McCarran was
absolutely ruthless in reeled in that
power so he turned him off quite soon
into one of the most powerful senators
that really Washington had ever seen and
he also had another lever of power which
was the Senate Appropriations Committee
which he was the chairman of the
subcommittee that controlled the budgets
for the Justice Department at the State
Department and a few other departments
so and we'll see later on how McCarran
managed to manipulate all these things
in in tandem so that in fact you know he
had control over legislation to include
Congress control over the people who
implemented many of these laws and a
great deal of influence even within the
White House bureaucracy of the
department's following these laws
implementing them well the first time
that McCarran and Truman really clashed
came in the aftermath of World War two
when Europe was awash in refugees you
know the war was one of the great
humanitarian crises of the modern era
and you know obviously the Holocaust was
enormous human tragedy that left
millions homeless in its way but there
are other refugees as well they were all
generally referred to as displaced
persons at the time now Truman the
Democratic leadership in the Republican
leadership and remember the Democrats
controlled both houses of Congress at
the time all agreed that America should
take war refugees and resettled them in
the country and legislation was duly
introduced to that effect McCarran
seriously more or less suggested that
they be resettled in Alaska well that
was an obvious non-starter before the
political pressure on both sides of the
aisle for in a legislation immigration
legislation so what McCarran did then
was to effectively stall the bill for
the better part of two years at one
point when it looked like he was going
to have to take the bill out of his
committee and bring it to the floor for
a vote
he announced suddenly that he was going
to take a three week fact-finding tour
to Europe three months later he came
back to the country now and meantime
he's gallivanting around Europe for 90
days instead of 21 days and he's doing
things like more or less opening up
diplomatic relations with Franco and
Spain now bear in mind that well for one
thing he's not a diplomat and he's not
even on the Foreign Relations Committee
Truman is trying to isolate Franco at
the time because well Spain is a fascist
fascist country and the war was supposed
to be about fighting fascism but to
McCarran the salient characteristic of
Franklin was that he was an
anti-communist and you know had shown
what he would actually do the Communists
in his country which is pretty much
killed them and so they Karen started a
sort of our approach wrong with Frankel
Spain that against Truman's expressed
wishes and the express policy of the
United States actually wound up becoming
diplomatic faint accompli eventually a
Frank will take it back into the UN he
once said the rest of the world needs
Spain more than Spain needs the rest of
the world and eventually under the Cold
War by polar pressures you know that
turned out to be true the West did
recognize Franco and accept fascist
fascists
Spain is a member of the international
community well you know so at one point
you pierson that Colin was referred to
me Karen is the senator from Spain other
people called in the senator from
Formosa and in Taiwan because of his
advocacy the nationalist regime there
even after had been driven off the main
man but we'll get to that in a minute
so McCarran is running around Europe
having a pretty good time he goes all
over the place meets the Pope asked for
a few favors for his family he had two
daughters who were nuns and he wasn't
shy of asking even the Pope for a you
know a little poll and he eventually
returns home and stalls a little while
longer but eventually the immigration
legislation is passed European refugees
will get to resettle in America so we
thought well three months later McCarran
passes the McCarran Internal Security
Act of 1950 which essentially spiked
immigration legislation with a host of
security provisions many of which
prevented refugees from resettling even
refugees who had cleared the security
provisions previously found themselves
suddenly back at square one you know
they had to meet a whole host of greatly
increased requirements to come to
America in one case a trainee in refuge
either I write about in the book got the
news in his family we're not going to be
able to come without reapplying and
starting all over again and he responded
by hanging himself well about this time
Joe McCarthy gives a speech in Wheeling
West Virginia which is considered the
start of McCarthyism and
history books most historians actually
allude to the fact that it had been
going on for several years but this
speech is kind of a focal point and you
know historians need some place to start
the story so usually the speech is
granted that distinction
McCarthy basically said that the State
Department's full of commies and Truman
was unwilling or unable to do anything
about that and this made him famous and
it caused really a firestorm of
controversy in from the next five years
McCarthy's was in the press more than
any one except for Truman and then
Eisenhower when he became president so
McCarthy had a you know developed an
enormous buzz and it really became
synonymous with the cause of zealous
anti-communism the point to this book
however is to place that into context
and so the the context here is that
conservatives and especially
conservative Democrats had been battling
the Liberals in Washington throughout
the 30s and 40s and at this point there
everyone who is anti-communist I'm going
to grant them you know a a wave run kind
of read their soul so you know I'll
assume everyone's sincere about it and
not but it doesn't mean they're not
opportunistic at the same time and it's
clear that the Conservatives really did
use the issue of communists in
Washington as a club with which to beat
the crap out of the Liberals at the time
so you know the use of a political issue
such as subversion might sound familiar
to some who remember this recent
election
well McCarthy was as I say the most
famous proponent of this sort of
hardcore anti-communist view but he
really didn't accomplish a whole lot he
would make a speech and say something
outrageous and get a lot of press for it
you would say someone like
Lattin Maura an Asian scholar was the
top Soviet espionage agent in America
then he would forget about Lattimore
move on and make some other accusation
that would get another headline
well McCarran didn't forget one of the
things that McCarran did after his
Internal Security Act was passed was he
created a committee in the Senate to
monitor how it was implemented so quite
honestly didn't trust Truman to
implement his law after all he was only
the president so McCarran formed the
Senate Internal Security subcommittee
and the first thing it did was it spent
18 months investigating on Latin more
know who McCarthy a you know accused of
being a Soviet spy Lattimore wasn't a
spy he had been in the 30s would used to
be called a fellow traveler at some
point he had been ideologically
sympathetic towards the Soviet Russia by
the 40s and 50s it probably moved
somewhat to the center if not to the
right but this didn't really matter in
1949 China had gone communist now this
was the biggest country on Earth largest
population in the world is suddenly a
communist nation and the US had been
aiding the nationalist regime Mao
somehow managed to win to people like
Truman his secretary of state gain a
chance it was just because the Chinese
decided to you know this was what how
things were going to be no they had a
civil war and the Nationalists were
corrupt and inept enough to lose it to
conservatives of McCarran and McCarthy
silk that didn't really explain anything
you know how could you know nationalists
lose with the aid of the greatest power
in the world the u.s. well you know it
had to be treachery someplace and it was
probably treachery in the State
Department and Owen Lattimore had been
an advisor to the State Department so
McCarran launched this probe that lasted
18 months into Latin War the State
Department
and it was really a incredibly thorough
which is not to say fair procedure that
in ended up in snerling people from a
whole host of universities and
departments in the government involved
the CIA one of the people who was caught
up in this was George Kennan the
architect of the containment policy who
found himself east out of government
partly due to his subpoena before the
McCarran Committee Latimer found himself
charge of perjury not any substantive
issues but because he had trouble
remembering things that had happened 15
years earlier and Truman wrote a letter
to what if his attorney general was
saying that well if anyone deserves to
be charged with a felony because of what
this committees been doing it's not
Latin Moore as obviously referring to
mccarran's other witnesses who were
accused of being committing perjury but
McCarran was only interested in pursuing
perjury
among those accused of helping the
Soviets not those who were
anti-communist well the Attorney General
under great pressure from McCarran did
indict Lattimore was thrown out by the
courts McCarran pressured another
Attorney General went to re-indict in
Latin Moore which happened thrown out
again but I mean this gives you some
idea of mccarran's tenacity his
relentlessness and actually his you know
amount of power he had getting actually
you know Truman's Attorney General to do
his bidding
columnist Murray Kempton referred to
McCarran has the de facto Attorney
General of the u.s. during the last
years of the Truman administration
Truman himself called McCarran simply an
sob now Paul Douglas one of the kinder
hearted people to serve in the Senate
referred to him as simply an evil man
well there was also the 1952 McCarran
Walter Immigration Act which
really mccarran's legacy and that in
effects enacted something of a
ideological wall around America it made
it much harder for people with any
radical associations to get visas to
visit the company the country it
resulted in quite a few people being
arrested who had been citizens or
naturalized citizens for years and
deported prevented people from getting
passports who were American citizens but
wanted to travel abroad if they fell
afoul of mccarran's a litmus test and
the act was implemented by the State
Department there are letters and that I
quoted in the book from some of Truman
aide aides complaining that there's
State Department bureaucrats at the
middle levels were following mccarran's
wishes and not Truman's wishes so you
know he once again the way McCarran
managed to sort of skillfully create a
law and then oversee its implementation
and you know the immediate effect of
this was that cruise ships would pull
into New York Harbor people would get
off and immigration authorities would
find their names on a list promptly put
them on a tugboat headed towards Ellis
Island where they were detained pending
deportation and they were told that you
know they had violated the law although
exactly how they had violated the law
was not something they were privy to so
they were allowed to contest their
deportation but not told what the
grounds were for deportation so in
effect you know if you were turned away
by the law of your recourse was to
either rot on Ellis Island or give in
and go home and you know in some cases
there were communists caught by this or
warmer fascist but in many cases people
like German war brides who had were
trying to join their husbands in the US
were caught up in this a delegation of
German students who had come to America
to study how democracy works found
themselves stuck on Ellis Island with an
all-expense open-ended trip there
well you know I can go on and on because
McCarran actually did he you know he he
was in his 70s by this time but he had
an enormous amount of energy and more
than that an enormous rancor and the
means to really vent his rage against
liberalism's and you know wasted no
effort to ever do that I think I'll read
you a little bit from this but I'll put
that into from the book but I'll put
that in the context by mentioning the
1952 Senate race which tells you a lot
about McCarran it's a high point of his
power and he's one newspaperman Hank
Green's button said the McCarran was
sixth in seniority in the Senate at
first in power the progressive magazine
that year said that McCarran and Truman
had been battling all year long and
mccarran's been winning every fight so
you know he's really at the peak of his
game and well what happens is there's a
newspaper in Las Vegas the only
newspaper in his state that actually is
critical of McCarran and one day the
newspaper finds that all of its
advertisers all of its which were
casinos suddenly decided on the same
morning to cancel their advertising well
the newspaper man Hank green spun didn't
think this was a coincidence so one of
the things he did he sued macaron is
became something of a cause celeb across
the country and so McCarran found
himself on their disposition being
deposed by lawyers and under oath was
asked about some alleged friends of his
like Bugsy Siegel the mobster who
basically built Las Vegas in the end of
the war McCarran claimed never to have
met him FBI wiretaps proven otherwise
but more importantly what happened was
that Greenspan championed a insurgent
Democrat who was running for the Senate
that year in Nevada
who was running for the junior Senate
seat McCarran had been grooming a
protege of his for this same spot and
everyone thought that mccarran's man
would win
well McCarran man actually lost so what
did McCarran do he supported the
Republican contender for the Senate seat
who with mccarran's backing won the
Democrats that year lost the Senate by
one seat
so essentially McCarran in a fit of
pique and rage brought down his own
temple upon himself he lost his
Judiciary Committee chairmanship managed
however to maintain much of his power in
the Washington Post he was almost as
powerful after the election it was
before because even as the minority
member of the committee he managed to
intimidate and cower the Republican
chairman Dwight Eisenhower compared
arguing with McCarran as to being like
beating on an anvil with a sponge
well McCarran left two years longer and
he dropped dead on the campaign trail
shortly after giving yet another speech
denouncing the communist menace and
about a month after he died McCarthy was
censured by his colleagues in the Senate
this is fall 1954 and so that's where
the book really ends with mccarran's
death in the car keys Center and I'll
read a little bit about the 1952 Senate
election as I write about it in the
chapter late in the book
this chapter starts with a couple of
quotes the first comes from Harry Truman
we came to the great gambling and merits
destruction hill known as Nevada
toko to look at it from the air it is
just that hell on earth there are tiny
green specks in the landscape where dies
who let crooked poker and gambling thugs
thrive such places should be abolished
and so shred Nevada it never should have
been made a state the country accounting
the great state of California to be too
much of a civil existence for that dead
and sinful territory think of that awful
sinful place having two senators and
congressmen in Washington and I'll ask
in Hawaii not being represented it's a
travesty in our system and a disgrace to
free government well I think you can
read into that perhaps Truman's feelings
about the senior senator from Nevada the
second quote is from the column mr.
Pierson lunched with government
Prettyman he gave me a long story of the
despotism of senator McCarran it was so
shocking that it was hard to believe
more like a story happening in Russia
and the chapter is called the dead and
it starts during an unusually cold
winter at 51 Chevy ku pulling a trailer
crawled into Las Vegas the young couple
in the front seat had $7,000 in a plan
and when of aigis this wasn't exactly
unheard of but town met chillings plan
was more updated than most wanted to run
for the US Senate against Pat McCarran
only McCarran wasn't up for reelection
for another four years
so McLean a Washington journalist with
no political experience was only tied to
the stake was the fact that his wife had
been born there had to settle for
running against mccarran's protege and
former law partner alan bible no
candidate in batter McLean recalled
within the past decade had ever run for
high office with even a hope of making
incredible showing unless he had behind
him McCarran political machine a good
deal of millionaire gambling money and
Nevada birth I had none of these the
post-war boom Nevada finally had more
people in square miles but just barely
McLean and his wife plan to spend eight
months and their life savings driving
around Nevada
going door-to-door across the state
bypassing the newspapers that printed
only what McCarran wanted them to print
taking his candidacy straight to the
voters don quixote 'no trailer people
called him that's the boys a gunner
surprise a lot of people his
father-in-law johnny did Grazia said
even in las vegas couldn't find someone
to take that bet across the room the
phone kept ringing it was March 24th
1952 and Hank green spun the owner and
publisher of the Sun was pounding away
with two fingers at his typewriter
riding his column for the next day's
paper railing against the prominent
brothel in the outskirts of town since
the town was Las Vegas he might as well
have complained about the dawn but for
Greenspun 43 was nothing if not [ __ ]
Asia's standing trim just over six feet
tall they brawlers nose and a mouth full
of go teeth usually clamp down on a
cigar Greenspun could have passed as a
former boxer indeed he approached
journalism like a barroom fight he threw
words like punches and he wrote to her
ignored the ringing Norman white papers
that manager walked order
we're in trouble he said in 30 minutes
he explained three big casinos had
pulled the business from the Sun the
Thunderbird El Rancho the last frontier
White's phone rang again Greenspan
followed him back to the desk the
Flamingo canceled its ads then the
morning got really bad another 8 casinos
walked away from the Sun almost a third
of the papers revenue had disappeared
before lunch not a single large casino
on the strip or downtown wanted anything
to do with the publication Greenspun
rushed out of his office on Main Street
jumped into his red convertible and
drove south for a few blocks until the
road merged into the strip another mile
Greenspan reached last frontier Las
Vegas seconds casino emotive court now
did it up in western theme park
beyond that slump the last casino on the
strip were taught and signed topped by
pink bird towered above a low-rise
building flamingo there glowed at night
and soft pink neon six years earlier
when Greenspan first drove down this
road there were only two motels and
fewer than 200 rooms on this trip he
came to talent promoter
tract instead he round up as Aflac
publicity agent from ups or mobster
bugsy siegel whose flamingos set off the
building boom this year the strip was
gaining another 500 rooms and would be
nearly enough for the prosperous hordes
of tourists decades to pound in the
decade the pound's population tripled in
Las Vegas showed no sign of slowing down
Grinspoon we left and pulled into her
driveway wrapping around in fountains
bringing water into the air the center's
stood a tower topped by a cloud shaped
sign supposed to be an artist palette
proclaiming Wilbur Clark's desert in
actual it was more that leaches desert
in Clark ran out of money during
construction had to give up
three-quarters of a stake to Morris died
elites got his start in the dry-cleaning
business in Michigan but found his real
meaty a as a rum runner and casino
operator in the sunny years after the
war dilates was one of many who
discovered that moving to Las Vegas
could change him overnight from the
criminal to the businessman the old way
of doing things died hard when boxer
Sonny Liston tried to pick a fight of
deletes the casino owner didn't blink if
he hit me [ __ ] he said you better kill
me because if you don't I'll make one
phone call and be dead in 24 hours
Liston kept his fist at his side tough
times that leads like to say call for
tough people Greenspan went in the front
door of the Desert Inn the DI everyone
called it stand straight up the back he
knew his way around it put his savings
into the casino and worked as its PR man
only defined like his friend Robert
Clark those role was being reduced in
significance Clark was contempt to see
his name on the marquee Greenspan went
out and bought a newspaper instead
putting his opinions in the front page
every day Brice Danny beans man called
his column behind the casino Greenspan
found deletes topping for another
architect but an 18-hole golf course
they were building deletes loved golf he
also loved guns
subject is no one had registered seven
guns of the Clark County Sheriff's
Office two FBI noted and therefore
should be considered armed and dangerous
what's going on beans man interrupt
you should know delete said why did you
have to attack the old man what business
it is is it of the Desert Inn or any
other hotel what I printed my paper
being spun and asked but it's in a
terrible position that leach replied you
know as well as I do that we have to do
what he tells us you know that he got us
our licenses and if we don't go along
you know what will happen to us when
deletes first came to the state in 1914
and he couldn't get a gambling license
something usually only slightly hard to
get it in Nevada the driver's license
McCarran took an interest in his new
constituents problem however and
phthalates got his license then in 1951
McCarran saved Nevada's gambling
industry from federal taxation now the
senator wanted the industry to squash
his loudest critic in the state dalits
knew whom to put his money on he was a
good investor a friend recalled Moe
never went against the tables behind the
men the Desert Inn sign rose above a
three storey tower the tallest building
on the strip which held the sky bar in
favorite place for people to watch the
mushroom clouds and occasionally erupted
in the her horizon for a year the
federal government had been exploiting
atomic bombs at the Nevada Test Site 65
miles north e west of town in Las Vegas
the ground could shake the sky turned to
fire someone would make book in how long
the world would last Greenspan glared
down at Dahl eats half a head shorter a
decade older he hated him during the
arab-israeli war Greenspan had smuggled
on sir Israel Daly's for the Arabs now
the mobster was trying to kill his
newspaper a Las Vegas Sun was
approaching its second anniversary and
might not see a third Greenspun stuck
his fist into his pockets if I hadn't he
remembered I probably would have used
him at the Thunderbird
where the neon chicken above the Marquis
bat-gas flames from its mouth nude ice
skaters keyboard in the showroom and
really narrow Howard Hughes was a
regular washing his on the shirts in the
sink there was always a booth reserved
from McCarran and his suite waiting for
him when McCarran asked the check and
never came the casino knew how to treat
politicians that should
one of its owners was Cliff Jones the
state's lieutenant governor whose idea
of business dress was a cask invest
cowboy boots who had 11 points in the
casino Jones didn't drink smoke or
gamble but he made a good living from
those who did and he had been in McLaren
supporters since the 1932 campaign
before Jones was even old enough to vote
he'd make a good lieutenant governor
someday McCarran told him he paid for
law school by working on Boulder Dam
then opened an office in the clothing
store in Fremont Street but most of his
legal business involved helping clients
get gambling license licensees and Jones
soon realized that taking a percentage
of the casino was more lucrative than
billing by the hour when the cleaning
store Bulow's office turned into the
Pioneer Club Jones took five points in
the deal at one time he had interest in
several different casinos mostly at the
Thunderbird which opened in 1948 the
year after he became lieutenant governor
the twin endeavors made Jones a very
useful person to know in Las Vegas the
big juice people called him juice and
local parlance was ability to make
things happen in Nevada only McCarran
had more juice majority owner who
Thunderbird was Marion Hicks went from
running a gambling boat off California
coast to building casinos in Las Vegas
and going 51 percent of the venture
Karen was fond of Hicks really knows the
game and he has a nice personality he
said once in Las Vegas in the 1950s
lawmakers and law breakers rubbed
shoulders together if a nonchalance
remark will even for Frontier boomtown
Nevada had finally found his true
bonanza a gold mine that can never be
dug dry legal gab gambling nearly a
century after Brigham Young had tried to
claim Las Vegas for the Mormons the town
more closely resembled Sodom and
Gomorrah in Salt Lake City Las Vegas was
not yet 50 years old but it was the
fastest growing city of its size in the
US population jumped from 8,000 to
24,000 would jump to 64,000 in another
decade at the end of World War II there
were two casinos on the strip before
1952 was over there'd be seven and three
blocks stretch of Fremont Street
downtown
already housed the densest concentration
of gambling in the planet only three
establishments weren't casinos a
drugstore which had slot machines a bank
and a 24 hour western union office we
give him what they can't get in Grand
Rapids said one local businessman let me
give it to him 24 hours a day
at first glance Las Vegas seemed too
good to be true like some sort of Mirage
shimmering in the desert palm trees
shaking pools that curved like a woman's
hips showgirls sunning themselves by day
mingling casinos at night cheap rooms
cheaper buffets piled high with shrimp
on ice and the slices of prime beef
showrooms where you could watch Frank
Sinatra or Eartha Kitt or Liberace no
minimum no cover on Saturdays and
Sundays there was three shows a night
which meant you could see six stop acts
over a weekend all for free of course
nothing was really free conventioneers
might be greeted with a clanging bag of
25 silver dollars but if you left town
with much change jingling in their
pockets from the gauntlet of slot
machines lining the way out of the
terminal at McCarran Airport which had
been named after him in 1942 the
supermarkets that took casino chips as
cash Las Vegas was growing rich any
single ineluctable proposition the house
on average never loses and Las Vegas was
nothing but one big house Liberace might
earn 50 grand a week for playing the
crowds and paid nothing to get to the
showroom thousands had to funnel through
casinos or slot machines pulled in
pennies and nickels and dimes and
quarters and silver dollars like magnets
but returned only a few pounds on the
ton and after a little more than an hour
of my version guests were herded back
into the casinos or dice tumble let
balls bounce blackjack dealers to turn
over each card like a personal favor
just to find a hotel lobby you had to
navigate a maze of green felt tables and
narrow passageways of the winking slot
machines whatever a casino spent in
attracting traffic came back in waves of
profit multi-million dollar
establishment paid for itself in half a
year
single Casino wore out 80 pairs of dice
they promise of the strip was that it's
casinos were somehow different in the
downtown gambling joins to gambling
gaming in the vernacular
well they wholesome recreational
activity could be enjoyed by Americans
and the post-war boom sort of like
television of odds reality was it was
just the same sucker's game dressed up
his family entertainment I used to be a
star on Broadway Tallulah Bankhead
admitted from the stage the sands where
she's earning $20,000 a week and now he
see me reduced to his shield for a
gambling joint gambling was changing
Nevada Reno was still the state's
largest city the Las Vegas which
accounted for most of the gambling
business was catching up and population
Minh boats which meant power which too
was shifting southward but as riches
gambling was for casino owners the real
money was the skim the cash had gushed
into the counting rooms we've never made
into the official books that was the
real jackpot a source of untaxed wealth
is limitless as human optimism and
accountability but from the Karen there
was paradox behind this prosperity when
he settled into his booth at the t-birds
powwow room and the stakes came the
tabbed in McCarran was acutely aware
that for all the visitors was shuffled
through the casinos that the state's
latest Bonanza was less to function in
every real economy than the exploitation
of yet another extractive industry
taking rocks out of the earth Sun during
the vows of marriage taking the coins
out of the pockets of visitors this was
found the VAT is sustained itself for
years in the Karen had struggled to
attract manufacturing spectacle commerce
to Nevada decade early had placed his
hopes and making easy and plan outside
of town we're going to build a great
industrial senator Clark County he had
beamed 1947 but five years later when
the plant had been turned over to
private industry was employed fewer than
3,000 people less than half the number
it worked in casinos the only industry
and then I was really able to flourish
in the desert soil was gambling Karen
had helped nurture that industry in ways
that he was glad to declare any ways
that he would never acknowledge from
McCarran then the Las Vegas boom was
both in a compliment to claim credit for
and a personal failure to lament source
with pride
as well as the Badgers saying I'm afraid
erupt her friend
we have blinkered our eyes to what is
the stronger form of economy namely
payrolls and legitimate businesses I
hope the time will come when the
financial structure of state of Nevada
will not rest upon gambling I hope the
time will come when we point with pride
to industries of all kinds in the state
with payrolls that will sustain the
economy but that isn't today Joe and it
won't be tomorrow the day would never
come
I'll stop there and anyone has any
questions I'd be happy to take him yes
sir you seem to disparage McCarran going
to Franco's Spain yet Roosevelt
recognized was the first president
recognized communist Russia and we had
trade and recognized Nazi Germany with
Nazi Germany we had trade and fastest
Japan up until almost World War two
started I mean what was the big deal
about him going to France well I mean
I'm sorry to Spain yeah good point and I
really wouldn't say that there's any
normative difference between some of the
countries of the US has had to deal with
over the years so I won't contest your
point I think if you have a question if
you can use the microphone that would
help
analogies with the present time are
unavoidable so let me just make a quick
one on my way to my question today
terrorism has become the Communist you
know the contemporary communism and we
can't help but look at the analogies now
what I'd like to ask is when McCarran
was you know exploiting the Communist
issue and and the only thing he had to
be to have power was to be
anti-communist didn't matter anything
else was there an opposition like today
there is a press and there is opposition
and there are some people in Congress
who are trying to oppose this and
there's opposition to the Patriot Act
and so on so they don't have a free hand
but I kind of get the impression the way
you talked that McCarran had a free hand
that he just nobody stopped him where's
their opposition and what happened to
the opposition well I'm glad you asked
that there was quite a bit of liberal
opposition unfortunately from my
perspective it was pretty much useless
if you look at the way McCarran managed
to sort of steamroll his his laws and
policies across Washington in the 50s a
lot of it had to do with the fear that
was literally in the air remember that
1949 China became communist the Soviets
exploded an atomic bomb
suddenly schoolchildren in Nevada were
given dog tags so that their bodies
could be identified in the event of
World War three coming to Manhattan soon
perhaps so there was a tremendous amount
of fear and anxiety in the air a rather
brave band of distinguished liberals in
the Senate people like Paul Douglas
Herbert Herbert lumen and they fought
really heroically at times against
McCann and I chronicled in great detail
some of their battles unfortunately they
always lost
Truman kept vetoing mccarran's laws
vetoes were overridden almost black
Kamlesh acclamation in Congress there
was 1951 of the years that I devote a
lot of attention to was an election year
and it was not a good thing to go on
record against opposing anti-communist
legislation that year so yes there was a
great deal of opposition I mean it came
from the White House which was you know
controlled both houses of Congress but
the temper at the times was such that
public sentiment was quite alarmed and
the majorities of both houses
continually supported McCarran in
McCarthy's style of anti-communism
McCarran have any sense of irony that he
was sponsoring anti-immigrant
legislation and yet he was the son of
immigrants himself not really during his
trip around Europe when he was delaying
the immigration refugee bill he popped
over to Ireland to visit the ancestral
village of his parents who had fled
Ireland in the 19th century from the
potato famine and gambled everything on
moving to the new world and starting new
lives
he got quite teary-eyed visiting his
relatives and realizing what his parents
had sacrificed so that he could have a
better life then he went back to refugee
camps in Germany and didn't get very
weepy when refugees would present their
stories to him questions Lyndon Johnson
was not Minority Leader but I think
majority leader during part of the time
that my character does your book touch
on any relationship to how he reacted to
him that's one the second one is the Joe
McCarthy we know he supported Joe
Kennedy we know he supported Joe
McCarthy financially to a certain extent
does he have anything to do with
McCarran at all well Joe Kennedy I
didn't find any thing about him
supporting the care
I wouldn't be surprised if he had the
macaron papers aren't complete they're
they're very rich but I have a feeling
that when his family vetted them before
turning them over to the University
Archives that they removed anything that
would have been too juicy as far as your
first question what was that again
Johnson oh yes yes yes Johnson was a
wellness McCarran says at one point as a
young man who someday might make
something of himself Johnson at one
point when he was running for the
position as a majority leader sent an
aide to every person in the Senate
trying to find out how they're going to
vote on a particular bill because
Johnson became famous for being able to
vote peak and he picked a predict
outcome of any any legislation really
and part of his legend that he
cultivated very assiduously well the
only senator from whom he got no
response essentially was McCarran
McCarran sent his aide back with a
message saying don't ever come to this
office again I don't know the answer
this morning do we know how Johnson
voted on the internal Securities Act and
the McCarran Walters act that was just
before see the vote in 1950 I'm not sure
Johnson was there for that 148 right but
I mean I don't remember if he was
actually there for the vote or not so I
don't remember how he voted responsive
under the gentleman's questions I think
you should be pointed out to get a
feeling of what the times were like the
Hubert Humphrey who was one of my
personal heroes Hubert Humphrey was the
one who introduced the bill to outlaw
the Communist Party which passed by the
way yesterday and it was Harry Truman
who instituted the loyalty oath before
McCarthy of required of all of all
government employees which gives you a
taste of what what it was like even
before McCarthy came on the scene right
well that's a very good point and you
basically you mentioned you liberal
contribution to
anti-communism and which is one of the
themes of this book actually I deal over
the course many years with the evolution
of liberal thinking towards communism
and Soviet Union in the thirties was as
trendy is it was almost acceptable to to
be quite radical I was pretty much the
high point of radical acceptability in
American politics and and later on it
was called the red decade the 50s was
obviously the anti red decade
so essentially what a good chunk of this
book is dedicated to doing is examining
in the context and how that changes from
the radical 50s of conservative from the
radical 30s to the conservative 50s and
you know McCarran is pretty much the
same during that period but the
zeitgeist changes quite a bit and he
goes from being in opposition during the
30s to being in domination in the 50s
and the liberal response to this changed
as well after World War two there was
such a thing as liberal anti-communism
bodied by organizations like the
Americans for democratic action who
believed that you know Stalin was as
evil as Hitler and both should be
opposed assiduously which is not always
the case during the 30s so you know
liberalism did change it was not static
and he evolved and in fact was at the
forefront of fighting the Cold War I
mean people like Harry Truman Dean
Acheson
were very decidedly anti-communist
however McCarran and many of the people
on the right and conservatives didn't
believe that or didn't give them credit
for their profession professions of
anti-communism and so you know a lot of
it I think is payback for it for the 30s
when the Conservatives had been really
abused and sickened by the way that the
Liberals sucked up to Stalin not all
liberals of course but so anyway you
know I can't examine this sort of
generational shift in American politics
and
you know I think that's a major part of
the story here so you know many of the
things that I'm sort of alluding to very
briefly here I do detail and you know
quite a few pages in the book anyone
else okay I can repeat your question
anti-communism of these two Irishmen due
to the influence of the Roman Catholic
Church well that's an interesting but
quite complicated topic and in a
mccarran's case particular and
particularly he was a Roman Catholic
attended church regularly became very
friendly with Carmen Cardinal Spellman
visited the Pope and so Amy it was it
was a Catholic but on the other hand two
of his daughters became nuns and this
was not something he was quite happy
about and he spent years trying to get
his daughters reassigned closer to
Washington in this way they could be
near him and eventually he succeeded but
his personal correspondence he's often
quite critical of the church for I
suspect because of its personality what
he was critical of is that the church
was vying for his daughter's attention
with him because he really you know you
know it was things like the White House
the that it can mean he really was a
person from an enormous Eagle ego and
did not you know really tolerate any any
rivals there's one of his critics once
said that there were three parties in
Washington the Republicans the Democrats
and McCarran kratts
and the mechanic rats were a party of
one but because of his power it was a
fairly enduring party so the church is
an interesting issue it's one that
unfortunately I wasn't able to really
tease out you know anything that I could
tell you other than how he felt about it
in any specific time
you know the the church was vehemently
anti-communist you know what part that
played in mccarran's anti-communist I
think was probably secondary ago to his
own sort of visceral loathing for it
well McCarthy was actually not that much
of a church group goer I believe he he
was Catholic
certainly culturally Catholic but was
not nearly as sincere as McCarran in his
anti-communism McCarthy was kind of
person who could give a fiery speech
denouncing the government and then turn
around and shake hands and want to go
out for a beer with the person he'd been
denouncing whereas McCarran really was
much more a grudge holder who was
consumed with these issues you know what
was it like to deal with such a
disagreeable person over a long period
of time good question
well McCarran was interesting because I
before I started writing the book I'd
done most of the research or and I wrote
his research at the same time for some
chapters but you know I knew the story I
mean and I knew how it ended and you
what he had basically done but I
actually did find myself continually
surprised really what a bastard he could
be I mean and I thought I knew because I
read this stuff I'd done the research
but then writing it out and chapters and
you know sometimes I found myself I
can't believe how persistent he was and
how he ultimately won this battle or
that battle so in a weird way I did
develop some admiration for some of his
qualities in the abstract as a tenacity
his persistence his you know principled
opposition so you know I yeah compared
in the book watching McCarran make laws
is being like watching a shark on the
hunt you know it's it's not really an
edifying spectacle but it's kind of a
in 81 any other questions
[Applause]
[Music]